the second episode of the final season
of Game of Thrones was a tense character
driven exploration of the moments
building up to the arrival of the knight
king's army of the dead in the impending
battle of Winterfell
between a love scene that took viewers
by complete surprise a sorrowful song
sung around the fire a knighting that
should have happened ages ago and Jon
Snow dropping the bombshell of all
bombshells fans are still buzzing but
the thing that has people really talking
is the plan to protect the castles most
vulnerable residents by hiding them in
the crypt below the castle I'm going to
be in the crypt with my son not to feel
a lot better with you down there to
protect us on first blush it seems to
make perfect sense there's no area more
secure in Winterfell than the crypts
after all there are only a couple of
entry points and any invading army would
need to fight their way through the
castles formidable defenses and
defenders to reach it there's one major
problem though this isn't just any army
it's the army of the Dead led by a guy
whose source of power is the ability to
raise the dead and control them and
guess what the Crypt is filled with Oh
naturally fans are freaking out about
this seemingly obvious flaw and John's
plan one fan wrote on Twitter everyone's
going to hide in the crypt with all the
dead Starks while an army who can raise
the dead approaches and no one foresees
a problem with that and another tweeted
they keep mentioning how safe the crypt
is going to be after years of watching
this show I'm sure that means the
opposite of course this was hinted at in
the promo clips for the final season as
the first teaser was called the crypts
of Winterfell and it showed the icy grip
of death coming for our characters in
the crypts in the episode three T's also
hints at this with clips such as Arya
Stark fleeing an unseen foe inside the
castle
not to mention this foreboding line from
Daenerys the dead are already here
perhaps most chilling is the fact that
there could be some familiar faces among
the night kings new minions after all
this is the stark family crypt meaning
John's mom Liana is among those who
could rise as
Rickon who died in the Battle of the
bastards and could we even see a
headless Ned zombie the mind shudders at
the thought your husband was an
honorable man should rest beside his
family in the crypts beneath Winterfell
though this horrifying theory may be a
surprise to fans of the show it's no
surprise to fans of the books in fact
this scene was seemingly foreshadowed
way back in the very first of George RR
Martin's A Song of Ice and Fire novels
where Jon Snow has a recurring nightmare
about this exact thing happening last
night he had dreamt the Winterfell dream
again he was wandering the empty Castle
searching for his father descending into
the crypts when he turned he saw that
the vaults were opening one after the
other as the dead kings came stumbling
from their cold black graves of course
this being game of Thrones
there's really no way of knowing what
will happen or who will live or die if
luck is on the side of the living
perhaps Arya will use her specially made
dragon glass outfitted sphere to slay
whites and White Walkers galore and the
little girl who swore to defend the
Crypt will keep her promise with fan
favorites like Tyrion set to be in the
crypts though fans are worried that
their worst fears will come to pass and
we may even see some of our most beloved
characters then rise from the dead to
fight for the night King all we know for
sure is that not everyone will survive
the next episode of Game of Thrones and
if this show gets any more tense
we might not survive watching it either
the things we do for love check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]